okay here i am again
with my selfie bar
got my hat on which keeps the sun off my
head
uh we've had three days in myanmar i
want to say it's one of the nicest
holidays i've had
one of the few things that's not nice
here in yangon is the traffic
it's been very interesting because if
you look at that billboard off in the
distance of course i can't read a word
so it's one of the few times i've been
in a country where i'm essentially
illiterate
but the people here are going to speak a
little louder with all the traffic noise
the people are so friendly such a nice
feeling
we were in yangon for two days then we
went to uh inle lake which is
spectacular it was an amazing experience
to travel on the lake
the people here are not rich but you
know you'll see a lady washing her
clothes in a stream and if you all you
have to say is mingle about and
everybody smiles back at you
we went to bagan
oh before that we uh in um
uh inle lake we actually stayed in town
called nyong's way which is a very
interesting little town they have a
winery up on the hillside 10 kilometers
out of time
out of town delicious wine
we had some shiraz red mountain shiraz
overlooking the vineyard and we could
see the lake in the lake
it was just victor and the friendliness
of the people and the quality of the
service was spectacular i recommend
myanmar began as an amazing
archaeological site with thousands of
pagodas and stupas
uh right by the river a lovely sunset
and one day
when i have time i'm gonna take all the
videos that i made and edit them and put
together a video of my uh a visit here
in myanmar but i hardly recommend anyone
that's looking for an interesting
destination friendly people interesting
things to see good food not expensive
make sure that you go to myanmar
one of the nicest holidays that i've had
in a long time
and now i'll
click this button here